Pete has got to be literally the best
human being I've ever met I love like I
can't say that too no dude I smoke weed
I've been in therapy since I'm seven I
watched like 90 Day Fiance Pawn Stars I
remember my dad died and my mom was like
your dad's dead but we got you a
PlayStation too and I was like yeah cool
I'm gonna push my mom down the stairs
and get a PS3 why do
attractive women
find Pete Davidson lovable
why why are good-looking successful put
together women why are they drawn like a
moth to a flame to Skeet to this sort of
meth addict looking sort of strange odd
creepy God why why we are joined
from Los Angeles by Lauren smoker an
actress model and host a past Miss
Hollywood who competed in both the Miss
America and Miss USA organizations
clearly an expert on what attractive
successful normal women think from
Kentucky we have Maria Montgomery Maria
is a former Miss Kentucky USA and
runner-up to Miss USA which is the
organization formerly owned by Donald
Trump has worked in SEC network digital
fam dual TV Pantene Olay and Covergirl
and Deborah Schwartzman from New York
who recently dyed her hair blonde a
conservative content creator from New
York City also TP USA Ambassador and
prageru influencer ladies thank you so
much for joining this scholarly panel
good thank you for having me yeah
yeah why do women find Pete Davidson
attractive
well honestly first I'd like to make it
clear I don't necessarily find him
attractive
um but I can see why a lot of women
would
um he's tall I hear uh he's very funny
and I think he has a very relatable
Persona and I know he's been very open
about his personal life so I know a lot
of women love a man who's emotionally
available so he's funny emotionally
available and Tall so there you go all
right Lauren respectfully I am calling
BS on two of those reasons I think
that's something women tell themselves
oh no we just want a guy who's funny
maybe look maybe that plays summer and
then the emotionally available I think
that's total BS I don't buy that for one
second I think nice guys finish last but
the point you make he's very tall that
was my hunch as well I suspect it is
because he is a very tall guy and
well there are other physical rumors
will we this is a family show we don't
need to talk about that Maria
one do you find skeet Davidson
attractive and two
if if you do or do not why do women
generally
I totally agree with Lauren I do not
find him attractive I think that is uh
pretty pretty clear for most females out
there I do think the height does help I
have a hard hard line as a tall person
myself that I don't you know I plays a
big role in that but also let's be
straight on as he's got he's got the
money to have the lifestyle of those
girls once but they don't need
technically so that gets a little sticky
but he does have the humor I do agree
that the vulnerability plays a role in
it he's very open which is a probably
always the case for whenever you're
dating other celebrities
um and I do think some girls just want
to to fix other guys like I hate to put
it that way but it is common to see like
a project and then they want to dive in
there and see what they can what they
can fix or they can change especially
because he is so open about his past and
his issues that's a great point the fact
that he's a degenerate actually is
probably attractive that's so you're
right I don't think it's the nice guy
thing exactly I think it's probably that
he's just a complete disaster of a human
being and women are drawn to that like
moths to a flame though I have to push
back a little bit on on this idea that
women are just drawn to his money I'm
sure lots of women are drawn to his
money but think about the women that he
has dated in particular I have this list
here half of them I've never even heard
of
Carly aquilino uh Cassie David that's
Larry David's daughter Ariana Grande
Kate Beckinsale Margaret quali I don't
know who that is and that's Andy
McDowell's daughter I don't know who
Andy McDowell is Kaya Gerber is Cindy
Crawford's daughter I'm assuming she's
pretty good looking Olivia O'Brien
Phoebe dynavor
Kim Kardashian Emily radakowski so at
least the women that I recognize on that
list
are very wealthy they don't need they
could just have the pool boy you know it
doesn't it's not like they're they're
chasing some diamonds or something they
can buy their own diamonds so Deborah
what's the deal
so I guess I'm standing alone here and
saying that Pete Davidson I do find him
attractive I don't know maybe it's just
because I'm from New York so I like his
style but I was gonna say that he is the
pool boy all the women that he's gone
for they're highly successful they're
very accomplished a lot of them have had
past marriages and I think at this point
in their lives they're just looking for
somebody to make them laugh to be
romantic to have a good time with
they're not looking for that strong
provider role which he clearly is not
they're kind of just looking to have a
good time and to feel good when they're
around him and I know that he's very
romantic and you forgot somebody on his
on your list there's rumors on Tick Tock
of him and Martha Stewart no what yes
Martha Stewart said on live TV she would
date him and then there was rumors that
he was trying to hit her up so I can't
confirm I wasn't in the room but there's
definitely a sense of like power amongst
these amongst these women that he's
going for and I think he's just the pool
boy but with a little bit more money
than the average pool boy I love Martha
Stewart and I really hope it isn't true
because it will get me to seriously
question her judgment but but you make a
good point as a New Yorker because
Pete Davidson does not look like a Ken
doll far from it he looks kind of like a
rough and dirty mutt you know as New
Yorkers tend to look like so I could see
that you know we we tend to be attracted
to the people that we grow up with you
know the the sort of culture that
cultivates who we are you bring up a
very interesting point though which is
that he has dated a lot of women with
past marriages and not like long ago in
the past marriages like he just like
they just broke up I mean most famously
Kim Kardashian Kanye West and Kim I
don't even think we're divorced yet and
then skeet just slides in there as the
as the rebound guy so do you think
that's part of it too that these women
you know look yeah he hasn't married any
of these women I don't know if he dumps
them or they toss him to the curb but
this is not some long-standing thing is
is skeet Davidson just a guy to have
around for a couple of weeks and then
these women get tired of him and then
move on to a real man that they want to
get married to Lauren
uh well I did read that when Ariana
Grande was dating him uh she it was
right after her she had just gotten out
of a previous relationship and she was
heartbroken and met Pete and it was fun
but also very impulsive she said I think
they were only engaged for about two
months I'm sorry dated for just a few
months before they got engaged uh and
then shortly after that they cut off
their engagement so the fact that he has
still very good relationships with all
of his exes
um tells me that he handles himself
really well within those relationships
but yeah what does that mean though you
know I mean the fact that he has good
relationships with his ex-girlfriends to
me actually suggests that he's way more
of a weirdo than I even thought that he
was you know it's just the whole thing
is so clinical he just moves on for a
month or two at a time and he dates
these girls and then they're just
friends again or something it's just so
sterile and clinical to say nothing of
the fact that he doesn't want to marry
these women kids and have a family it's
so icky and creepy I don't you know I I
don't want I like to think that my
ex-girlfriends mostly don't hate my guts
but you know I when I think about A Love
Affair I want it to be a love affair I
don't want it to be some well we just
had a relationship for a couple of
months and then we moved on and had a
handshake no I want it to be passion I
want Lord Byron I want Casanova I want
these women to be pining over me at
night howling to the Moon okay and
nobody seems to do that with Pete
Davidson so Deborah since you're the
only one who finds the guy actually
attractive is he just the sort of guy
that you would want to have a rebound
fling with you know a shoulder to cry on
who will get your your face tattooed on
his neck or something or is he the kind
of guy that you could see yourself
potentially marrying
so I think you're underestimating how
romantic he is there was a lot of
stories that came out when he was dating
Kim that he would buy her so many
flowers do all these little thoughtful
things so I think that aspect of his
relationship and the way he behaves with
the women that he's dating I think
that's how he gets them because he Wows
them but I think this all comes down to
his daddy issues I love him as a
comedian he used to always make jokes
about his dad dying during 9 11. that's
just his humor I don't know but I think
it's a lot of daddy issues where he like
hasn't had a strong male figure in his
life so possibly he has this very like
emotional sweet side to share with these
women but these women come from such
powerful relationships in the past
they've all dated very high power men
and I think once they realize ah he's
not going to be mean enough to me or ah
he's not going to be strong enough for
me they just dump him because all these
women have dumped him he proposed Ariana
he's initiated all these relationships
and he keeps getting tossed to the curb
but he's honestly upgrading
that is true is if you're going to get
dumped by these women I guess uh you
know if if you end up with Emily
radakowski or something you know that
that's not your wedding so you bring up
the daddy issues and I have noticed that
about him I mean that that's really the
only fact I knew about Pete Davidson was
that his dad was a firefighter and was
killed on 9 11. so obviously very very
traumatic thing and he would joke about
it in this way that doesn't seem very
healthy but then again I'm not sure I've
ever met a totally healthy comedian in
my life so you know they're all a little
bit crazy and so does that play a role
in it as well that actually I've made a
mistake bringing all of you out here
because you are normal people who are
giving normal and rational analysis but
both Pete Davidson and the women that he
is dating are just completely insane and
there's no reason to apply any logic or
rigor to that at all Maria
I think there might be a touch of Truth
in that the reality is these girls are
boss babes they are used to the
spotlight they're used to essentially
running their own business for what they
do in the media and I think someone like
him whether it be daddy issues that
maybe they may or may not be able to
relate to or maybe it's just simply that
he's fun and an escape from the
stressful realities that they live every
day could have a lot of weight and why
he keeps being able to pull these girls
and also I think one thing to take into
consideration is Paparazzi they're you
know they're following these people
around and so maybe they're catching
them
in situations where it is still somewhat
early and they are just that that fun
relationship that friendship that that
rebound and so to us we take it as so
much more serious but in reality they
are just friends and that's why he's
able to maintain those friendships after
the breakup possibly I know there's some
things that show when the relationships
may be deeper than that but that isn't
optional right right that's true that
the moment that Pete Davidson goes out
with one of these girls it's all on the
magazines in the supermarket but
actually maybe they just go out on a few
dates and they do whatever and then
that's it and they move on no big deal
have a handshake okay that that makes
sense to me before I let you go people
write in all the time to the show asking
for relationship advice
uh now I don't think that a single one
of the men who write into this show
Aspire in any way to be Pete Davidson
but they probably want to land some gals
who are as pretty as Pete Davidson's
girlfriends so if we could do a sort of
rapid fire down the line starting with
you Lauren then Maria then Deborah
what do you look for in a man what do
the men listening to the Michael Knowles
show need to do to land the beautiful
virtuous sweet little honey of their
dreams
well I as far as confidence goes like we
were saying with Pete Davidson I think
that is for me one of the most important
things confident yet uh has the ability
to be humble I think a lot of men
um their confidence kind of supersedes
to where uh they can come off as
arrogant
um so I think being able to be confident
yet learning when to be humble in the
right situations goes very far for me
I totally agree with the confidence part
but to take that a step further to just
simply be yourself don't worry about who
she dated in the past or what you think
she may like because it may be
incredibly inaccurate so just whatever
you can bring to the table drop your
guard and just bring that to the table
and if it doesn't work out it shouldn't
work out in the first place so instead
if you're able to just be yourself then
you're gonna go into be more confident
you're going to have more fun it's going
to be more natural it's not going to be
forced and ultimately you will find
someone that is attracted to that
agree with all the points made so far
and I would like to add that if you're
trying to specifically date a woman
who's more accomplished or more powerful
or has just had more experience in her
life I definitely think men need to
channel this Mantra of like being in
control but not being controlling women
want to feel protected we want to feel
safe but we don't want to feel like we
have to ask you permission to do things
I want to feel like you're going to
protect me and support me but you're not
going to tell me what I can or can't do
and I think that's kind of his chart
with these women he can control himself
he has stuff going on for himself he's
not trying to tell them what to do how
to dress in a way that Connie did to Kim
Kardashian he's just letting them live
while also being like I love you I'm
going to support you let's have a good
time and what else can accomplished
women want besides just peace and
calmness yeah Beyond just a guy who is
easy to completely steamroll and just
doesn't have opinions about anything and
it's just a total total loser yeah no
right interesting um I I think there's a
lot of Truth to what you're saying in
that you don't want a guy who's just got
this iron tyrannical Gray rip and says
oh you know I mean I think frankly Kanye
was right to tell Kim Kardashian to you
know dress a little bit more modestly
every now and again but but you don't
want a guy who's going to be nitpicking
every aspect of your life you you want a
guy who just as you're talking about
Lauren and Maria is confident enough
to be a little looser and be uh you know
just a little bit more normal and have a
kind of humility and uh not not fasten
that that grip on power because very
often we see these things as opposites
humility on the one hand and I don't
know
confidence on the other but in my
experience the most confident people are
the most humble people and the most
boastful people are actually the least
confident people because
the people who who keep that tight grip
on power
they feel it slipping away I mean that's
why when people feel their control
slipping away that's when they tighten
up and so I could absolutely uh see that
as as being part of why some deluded
women find P Davidson attractive and
then of course uh in addition to that
advice of be confident be humble be
supportive be kind be normal I think all
three of you would agree be tall
yeah absolutely okay all right well good
advice for everybody Lauren Maria
Deborah thank you so much for being here
just going down the line starting with
Lauren Lauren where can people find you
uh Lauren smoker on Instagram okay Maria
same for me Instagram's gonna be the
best place which is at Maria Montgomery
m-a-r-i-a Deborah also on Instagram it's
the Deborah Leia Lea it actually
reminding us it just occurred to me I as
I said that I said wait a second I've
just done a whole topic with uh
beautiful women about how men should
approach them and then I just gave out
their Instagram so apologies if your
inbox gets uh guys don't be come on
don't be weird no none of the DMS okay I
think we're used to it at this point
honestly yeah let's slide into my idea I
could you know oh well I guess I guess
uh we'll have to discuss that on a later
episode Laura and Maria Deborah thank
you so much for being here I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
we will see you all
[Music]